I think the great thing about having students
who have really deep knowledge of math and
science in these classes is that they draw
upon that in the way that they think about
math and science.
So it's not just about math that, you know,
happens in a textbook that lives on a piece
of paper, but math that's embodied in engineering,
math that's embodied in their lives, math
that they can kind of think about in interesting
and different ways.
Same with science, you know, it's about science
in practice that they may have done from a
UROP on campus, or from some other experience
that they've had interacting with faculty
that have done research in those areas.
So they can bring that to the classroom -- they
can bring their own experience and their own
passion for Math and Science.
They bring so much to the classroom.
And I don't need to sort of say like, "Well,
you really need to understand what's great
about science before you understand how to
communicate that to students, or to understand
what's great about... that math is a language
that we can use in lots of ways.
You need to understand that before you can
teach math."
I don't need to do any of that for the students
here, and students who come from more diverse,
sort of backgrounds with their own experience
with math and science do sort of need to learn
that first.
They need to understand what's great about
science; they need to understand how math
is a language that helps us understand the
world.
And so I think that if I were teaching in
a different university, I'd probably need
to help students learn that first before they
actually tried to convey that to their own
students, and I'm fortunate enough to not
have to do that here.
For most of the students, math and science
have always come really easily to them.
They've sat in a room, someone's perhaps lectured
at them, and they've kind of gotten it.
They can do well on the tests, and they can
move on.
And, sometimes it's a struggle for them to
think about, "Why... why is this student not
getting it?
You know, the teacher told it to them just
like they told it to me, and yet I understood
it and this student didn't."
And it's a matter of trying to think about,
"How do you break that
down to help them understand that everybody
sort of thinks about the world differently
and thinks about their own learning differently?"
and how to accept that challenge.